the crypto markets are crashing and two
of the world's largest cryptos luna and
ust face extinction from a multi-billion
dollar bank run that's billion with a b
as of recording i still don't know if
these coins are going to recover and the
big question on everyone's mind is how
did this happen i brought on an expert
to explain it but first we have to talk
about the basics of this stuff terra usd
also known as ust is an algorithmic
stablecoin which is different from
fiat-backed stable coins like tether
which at least pretend to be backed by
real money algorithmic stable coins on
the other hand aren't backed by anything
the way they maintain their peg to the
us dollar or euro is with market
dynamics by incentivizing arbitrage
usually there's a pair of tokens one of
them paired to the currency and the
other can fluctuate and i'm not going to
get into exactly how this arbitrage
thing works because it's quite
complicated and others have covered it
in a great amount of detail the point is
is that usually these things work really
well and make a lot of money for
everyone right up until they don't and
things go boom historically every single
algorithmic stable coin has eventually
lost their peg in what's known as a
death spiral where people lose their
faith in the coin finally and rush for
the exit and because this stable coin is
not collateralized in any real way most
people end up losing their money in
these exit situations famously mark
cuban got wrecked with a stable coin
called iron and it's titan pair many
people have compared this token pair to
ust and luna however there are
differences which we're going to get
into but the point is there's been a lot
of failure in the algos stablecoin space
which you need to know about people meme
about all the different failures and say
look you guys are trying alchemy it's
impossible you can't create value from
nothing despite this fact it hasn't
stopped people from trying every time a
new algorithmic stable coin fails two
more crop up with new strategies about
how they're gonna finally defeat this
death spiral and the most popular and
successful attempt at this has come from
terra labs a company which created luna
and ust these two coins are extremely
popular and in the top 10 of all
cryptocurrencies so the project is
massive and if these coins were to go
bust billions of dollars would vanish
one reason the people have invested so
much into ust and luna is because of a
savings protocol called anchor which
promises people a stable return of
around 20 which is obviously
insane especially given how stable
stable coins are supposed to be as a
reminder bernie madoff only promised a
stable return of 10 percent a year and
the anchor protocol is nearly doubling
that leading many people to accuse it of
being a ponzi scheme however luna
investors who often call themselves
lunatics say everyone knows these rates
are unsustainable and claim they're just
being used as a growth tactic to get
people into the ecosystem and that they
will eventually be lowered over time as
of a day ago there was 14 billion
dollars locked up into this 20 a year
free money scheme and this has been one
of the major drivers of adoption and
this 20 return was seen as a great
investment for many right up until the
crypto markets went into free fall over
the weekend and luna and ust were hit
some of the hardest of all luna fell 50
percent in one day and ust actually d
pegged all the way down to 69 cents
nice as for the anchor protocol there
was roughly seven to eight billion
dollars withdrawn from the protocol over
the course of a couple days like i said
billion dollar bank run and as of the
time of writing i really do have no idea
if ust is gonna recover at all and
that's why i brought on my guest today
bennett tomlin he's something of a
stable coin specialist and you may
recognize him from my tether video and i
couldn't think of a better person to
talk to to really get to the bottom of
this bennett thanks for coming on the
show so this is absolutely insane we
have billions of dollars hanging in the
balance here and i guess my question is
what are the scenarios here which ways
could this go sure so the first way this
could go is that people continue to lose
confidence in this system
and um
try to exit their terra into luna which
when you do it below peg mints more luna
and provides continued downward pressure
on the price of luna which is the
algorithmic stable coin death spiral
that's often talked about is once the
confidence is shaken it can feed into
itself and as the protocol is trying to
protect itself it's also destroying
itself by
draining any of the remaining value out
the other option is that
dokuan and terraform labs are able to
using their bitcoin reserves by
partnering with appropriate market
makers and venture capitalists that
they're able to at least for now get
this back to peg once they have it at
peg they're going to need to
convince the community that this is
still a thing worth having confidence in
what you might see in order to try to
get that confidence back is dokwan and
terraform labs
or perhaps just the terror community
broadly may try to
find a scapegoat some kind of entity
firm or
person who they can come up with a
plausible motivation for wanting to
attack tara i'm already finding that by
the way they're coming out and saying
that you know centralized banks want to
bring terror down they want to take down
luna so you're already seeing that occur
but one of the interesting things i
thought about the luna fountain
foundation guard or whatever it's called
is that they bought bitcoin to
supposedly protect the lunapag but since
the markets are pretty correlated when
the markets go down like this and you
have like an attack on the peg aren't
they selling bitcoin at a loss to
protect luna and then making bitcoin
crash even harder like am i getting that
right why would you invest in an asset
that would probably be down when you
need it the most because i think
taquan's goal with purchasing the
bitcoin wasn't really to
stabilize the peg or make the terra
system better
i think that the
primary goal with purchasing this
massive amount of bitcoin
was to make it harder for people who
care about bitcoin to criticize luna or
tara because he was on pace to become
like one of the single largest holders
of bitcoin in the world and once you're
in that position
you have a lot of influence over
bitcoin
and you can get a lot of things you may
want because no one wants you to
suddenly market sell 10 billion dollars
worth of bitcoin that would be very bad
for anyone who holds bitcoin or anyone
who holds assets heavily correlated with
bitcoin which is the entire
cryptocurrency market they've now made
it where criticizing tara criticizing
luna and destabilizing their system
risks destabilizing a larger portion of
the crypto ecosystem as a whole and as
such
many
perhaps all crypto holders now have an
incentive to try to make sure that luna
and tara survive i think also another
part of this that we have to talk about
is obviously
their success with the anchor protocol
or i call it success they've been
offering these crazy 20
rates of return can you explain it's
this weird game it feels like bernie
madoff the whole like you get this
really stable return
um actually it's way over what bernie
madoff was offering can you explain like
explain that i know they're saying that
look it's just a growth hack
but
i it feels
it feels awful ponzi-like
why are you laughing
yeah i i'm laughing because when cass
and i did our episode on tara there's
the moment when we talk about this and
cass asked me why does this feel like a
scam i'm like it feels like a scam
because they're telling you they can
guarantee a 20 interest rate and when
someone tells you that they're basically
always scamming you
that's that's not a real thing that
generally happens um and so for a long
time tara form labs was providing funds
while they're still providing funds
terraform labs is providing funds to the
anchor protocol so that you can get
a rate higher than the market can
support for lending out your tara it did
used to be this like guaranteed stable
20 percent uh or so 19 whatever percent
yield uh they recently did make it so it
starts to float a little bit but it's
still subsidized so that it
you get more for lending it than you get
then you pay to borrow it
um crazy idea and only in crypto by the
way only in crypto yeah yeah normally
that goes the other way uh the good
faith explanation for what they were
doing is that they hoped they could get
this big enough that it would actually
start being used for like
real things commerce or foreign exchange
or payments or
currency things things currencies are
used for but instead everyone just used
it for the free money
and eventually free money ends
right right well it seems like every
time a stable coin fails an algo stable
queen fails it just seems like somebody
has a new idea for oh i know what they
did wrong i'll i'll fix it this time
this is going to be the one true
see i i wish they had new ideas
you don't think they do
this like tara is not very meaningfully
different from like the economic
concepts behind dan larimer's new bits
from like 2015 or
not yeah new bits bit shares from like
2015 or um it's not super meaningfully
different from the titan and iron
finance one which
famously broke and lost mark cuban this
one just feels very well funded yes and
it feels like this one's big i think
what makes terra so interesting is none
of the other algorithmic stable coins
have grown to 18 billion dollars
dokuan and terraform labs were way more
effective at marketing and growth than
any of the previous algorithmic
stablecoin teams
and because of that it got to a scale in
size where it ended up posing this uh
relatively unique risk to the
uh cryptocurrency ecosystem that no
algorithmic stablecoin has really been
able to do before because they were
always so much more isolated it was a
lot
easier to call many of the older ones
ponzis or really emphasize the game or
the scheme part because they were a lot
less likely to interact with other
protocols and to become this more
broadly accepted part of the ecosystem
but there's places that had ust as a
base pair and stuff for exchanges right
like this had started to reach out into
a broader part of the ecosystem now
we're talking about a stable coin that
was able to sponsor a u.s sports team
right and so like it's
it's entirely different and it's way
more deeply connected and so seeing it
play out in this way has been a bit of a
contrast to past algorithmic stablecoin
blowouts and might perhaps give us some
idea
of what might happen if say a stablecoin
about four four and a half times the
size of terra were to suddenly become
much less valuable
frightening and i hope that doesn't
happen anytime soon thank you so much
bennett for coming on and explaining all
this stuff to us guys bennett and his
co-host cass have a podcast that i want
you guys all to go listen to you want to
shout it out real quick
uh yeah sure caspianzi and i are the
co-host of cryptocritic's corner you can
find it on youtube or anywhere else you
listen to podcasts great podcast i
listened to it myself um thank you so
much for jumping on and explaining these
what's happening crazy times stay safe
out there we'll see you